tras establecer un récord de seis meses
en el espacio el más largo de la
historia para los taikonautas chinos la
tripulación de tres personas de la
última misión china la sien su 13
finalmente regresó a la tierra
tras aterrizar en el desierto de gobi
los astronautas recibieron una cálida
bienvenida a su vuelta
al mismo tiempo me gustaría decirle a mi
hija que su madre que prometió elegir
una estrella está de vuelta
[Música]
es realmente una prueba para mí
completar mi primer vuelo espacial de
medio año en este momento he realizado
mi sueño espacial y puedo informar con
orgullo a la patria de que todos los
amos de buena salud
así
el trío partió al espacio el pasado
octubre para trabajar en la primera
estación espacial permanente del país
tiangong que significa lugar celestial
la misión marca otro hito en la búsqueda
de china para convertirse en una gran
potencia espacial aunque ha llegado
relativamente tarde a este campo
china ha recorrido un largo camino para
alcanzar a sus rivales de eeuu y rusia
dos países que han dominado la
exploración espacial
cómo
en 2003 china se convirtió en el tercer
país en enviar a sus astronautas al
espacio cinco años después el país
completó su primer paseo es radial la
construcción de la estación espacial
tiangong finalizará este año china tiene
grandes ambiciones en el espacio quiere
enviar seres humanos a la luna en 2029